Marvel Studios Black Panther has brought
King to charla and his home country of
Wakanda to life drawing inspiration from
the hundreds of Black Panther comics
virtually every character in the film
was inspired by a comic book counterpart
and while they might never see the same
twists and turns and the movies that
they did in the comics there's a lot
more to them than you might have thought
here are the characters from Black
Panther who might just have a little
more meaning than you realized and in
case you haven't seen the movie yet
spoilers ahead
sureiy in the film the tisha write plays
Cherie the young technologists
responsible for the Black Panthers
vibranium power Tech in the comics
however her role wasn't limited to
fighting alongside two chala in 2009 she
actually replaced him while Sheree
wasn't introduced until almost 40 years
after by Panther first appeared in 1966
her rise to prominence came pretty
quickly after losing the Black Panther
identity twice the Charla decided that
he'd be a lot better off choosing his
own successor since Sheree was as
closest relative and since she'd already
proved her Vala by defending Wakanda
against an invasion by Klaw he chose to
train her sure enough her ascension as
Black Panther later became necessary
after T'Challa was injured to the point
of death Shuri took the heart-shaped
herb and became the new black panther
and the ruling queen of Wakanda whether
or not the movies will follow this
storyline remains to be seen but as
we've already seen her as a capable
warrior in battle and the brains behind
the Black Panthers tech we wouldn't rule
it out Ulysses Klaw
despite being the character who links
Black Panther to the earlier
installments of the MCU Ulysses Klaw as
played by Andy Serkis isn't exactly the
major villain of the movie instead he
makes his exit about halfway through a
red herring that works so well because
in the comics Klaw is one of Black
Panthers most enduring archenemies like
the version in the film's comic book
Klaw wasn't a moral arms dealer with a
keen interest in vibranium and even
sported the sonic arm cannon in place of
his left hand the big difference though
is that his abilities didn't stop there
in a desperate attempt to gain
superpowers that would make him the
equal of the Fantastic Four Klaw
transformed himself into a being made of
living sound waves Klaw became a
supervillain his career that saw him
battling against the Fantastic Four
daredevil and life
and forming a hatred that would see him
amassing an army of supervillains to
invade Wakanda but the question is
whether the movie version of Klaw will
make a return in a form that's closer to
his comics counterparts as good as
Circus is in the role and as nice as
there is to see his actual face for once
you don't hire the world's most famous
motion capture actor if you're not
planning on turning him into a being
made of pure sound mbaku
one of the biggest surprises of black
panther came in the form of mbaku -
Charlie's first challenger to the throne
of Wakanda played by Winston Duke mbaku
is the leader of the jabari tribe who
have withdrawn to wakanda's mountains
where they live without dependence on
vibranium his towering physical presence
and sense of humor make him one of the
movie's most memorable characters but
given his comic book roots it's kind of
a shot to see him bark you in a movie at
all created in 1969 he originally
operated another rather unfortunate name
of man ape the idea was to tie him to
another jungle animal in the same way
that - Charlie drew his powers from the
panther a deeper social implications
made him a pretty awkward supervillain
to have around the movie avoids a lot of
the awkwardness by just calling him
mbaku and toning down his costume a
little while still keeping nods to his
comic book roots they're small changes
but they make a whole lot of difference
as for where he goes from here the movie
embark you does something that he never
did in the comics he formed an alliance
with two chala considering that Winston
Duke is already listed in the cast for
Avengers infinity war it's safe to say
that this alliance is going to last at
least for now
Zuri on the screen
Zuri is the spiritual leader of Wakanda
a priest and advisor to both - Charla
and his father - charka the comics tell
a different story
Zuri was one of the Black Panthers
closest advisors but his concerns tended
to be more on the physical side he was
considered one of Akhanda strongest
warriors and even got into a fistfight
with Thor of course since it was Thor
they became good friends after their
throwdown sadly both versions of Zuri
managed to meet their ultimate fate at
the hands of a super villain in the
comics though it was drawing an invasion
of Wakanda by morlin a spider-man
villain who basically eats animal-themed
superheroes that's a pretty unlikely
fate even for the Marvel movies but the
real tragedy here is that we lost out on
Forest Whitaker and Chris Hemsworth we
ding Duchin Dylan's epic handshake from
the opening scene of predator a Oh of
all the characters in Black Panther who
deviated from the comic book roots AO
played by Florence kazoomba was the one
who sparked a minor controversy in the
MCU she's one of the dormer Milosh a the
order of potential wives in training who
also service work and as security forces
but not much more
in the comics however she became one of
Marvel's most prominent LGBTQ characters
shortly after being introduced her lover
Anika started out as a combat trainer
forming a tense relationship that
developed into much more unfortunately
Anika was convicted of a crime and while
AO pleaded with the reigning queen to
spare her life it didn't work instead a
Oh broke her out and the two became
vigilantes in Wakanda known as the
midnight angels while a O's orientation
was only hinted at in scenes that were
ultimately cut from the film her story
did take center stage when Marvel
launched black panther world of Wakanda
with the first arc focusing on AO and
Anita's history Nakia in the film the
pizza Nyong'o plays Nakia as to
Charlie's love interest an ex-girlfriend
who devoted her life to working in
secret as a spy in the end as she steps
out of the shadows to defend makanda and
even steps back into a very close
personal relationship with the black
panther in the comics not so much while
Nakia was introduced as one of the
original Dora Millar J in 1998 she
didn't stay as one for long to Charla's
interest in the dora melash a was purely
ceremonial but Nakia harbored an
infatuation with the super heroic king
that grew to the point of obsession
causing her to attempt to murder the
Black Panthers former girlfriend the
monocle in the kir was dismissed from
his service and eventually we emerged as
an enemy named malice it seems unlikely
that the MC used the Kia will follow
that path but it's a lot easier to
believe that something might drive a
wedge between the Kia and the charla to
make drama in a future film after all
since they're broken up at the start of
the movie it's something that's happened
to them before thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]